this is big news and as we're talking
about Nikki Haley I think it's important
to bring up this video now I'm not 100%
sure this is the correct video not an
accurate video that's from 2021 that's
not an accurate video okay good thank
you for pointing that out y we have this
report from ABC News houthi fired
missile strikes a uh a missile strikes a
us-owned vessel off Yemen in the Gulf of
Aiden raising tensions so we're now
hearing not only is the US and the UK
bombing this uh the houie rebels they're
firing on US own ships they fired on us
warship
war is escalating in a very very
dangerous fashion even if it doesn't get
crazier from this point and this is the
level it's at trade is going to be
heavily affected your the cost of your
goods is going to go up Nikki Haley is
the candidate of more war for an
intervention and lying about it the
whole way through Yep this is why as I
know we're supposed to be this honorable
news program program checking the
results no Nikki haly is awful don't
vote for her I hope she loses otherwise
World War I so uh uh Jason Miller the
Trump campaign ruled out today
uh v as VP but did not rule out Nikki
when asked but break this down for me
what do you mean he I saw the clip he
was asked could dicki Haley presumably
be the VP and he's like that that's in
the cards or something to that effect he
didn't rule it out why ultim well there
could be oh gosh Laura Trump or Kimberly
guilfoil they also you if you look at
the you look at all the establishment
political analyst they're going to Trump
and they're telling them it makees sense
for Trump not to say yes or no also
makes sense for him because he could uh
essentially stop Nikki from attacking
him during the election cycle by
possibly maybe giving her a possibility
and therefore she's she's going to have
to be careful with the criticism that
she launches against him so
strategically when you look at the
situation anything and everything is
plausible here but I think as
Independent Media we need to send out
the message that Nikki Haley is horrible
she is awful we talked to to tuer
Carlson specifically about this and I
asked them would you support uh Trump
Nikki ticket and Tucker Carlson said
absolutely not think I think I think we
need that message out there more than
said more than that he said I'd leave
the protest against that I I can say
this Trump has always promised that he
will fight who's ever in second place
and for the longest time Ronda Santos
was in second place and so Nikki Haley
didn't face the ire but if you're
starting to pay attention now Trump's up
you know his super Pack's done a couple
million dollars and attack ads against
Nikki Haley in New Hampshire uh and
there's a ton of material Nikki Haley's
been public office for over 20 years
she's 20 years of baggage you get to go
through 20 years of stupid statements
and and terrible policies that she
supported and uh she's about to feel the
heat because she's in second now and uh
she's not going to enjoy being in second
who knows if she's there for long uh
maybe V is the the the last man standing
ultimately after you know besides Trump
has Trump attacked Nikki oh yeah he
calls her bird brain uh he thinks that
she's a stupid person so he calls her
birdb brain he's not wrong um you know
uh there there's great ads up right now
showcasing Nikki you know being being
more concerned about protecting the
feelings of illegal aliens than
protecting our borders uh she she really
doesn't want you to call illegal aliens
criminals and so she's incredibly weak
and you're going to see a lot more of
that I'd assume now that she's firmly in
second place I think Trump is the
incumbent it's like a second term
president so like at this point I hope
that he focuses on what and telling us
what he wants to do next like it is very
important rally go to agenda 47 go to
Trump donaldjtrump.com and go to agenda
47 every policy position for his next
term for next Administration uh and I
can promise you that he's already been
doing a great job of of looking at
Staffing for the next administration
because that was something that uh you
know it could have been a little bit
better in his first term obviously uh
and he's taking it very seriously for
this next term it could have been way
better the first time but I get it that
they were like I think Don Jr was on the
show being like you know you get in
there the first time you're like whoa we
won we've got three weeks to staff this
people are telling you pick this guy
pick this guy pick this guy and you're
like I I guess I'll go with so I I think
we assumed that you have an r in front
of your name you're on our team that's
what we thought and you know he got in
there and then he early on you learned
that's not that's not the case and so um
he he found out who his friends were he
found out who he can trust who he can
put in these positions and he's had four
years to think about it he calls this
period that we're in right now a pause
period and uh you know he he's very
excited to get back in there yeah his VP
pick is going to be crucial it's going
to be absolutely critically important to
see his trajectory and for from my
vantage point an anti-establishment
figure makes more sense than an
establishment figure because if someone
in the establishment they're just going
to take him out it's it's quick it's
easy the CIA has heart attack guns
decades and decades ago it's guaranteed
but if it's anti a lot about this if
it's a very strong anti-establishment
person they're going to have to think
twice it has to be someone more radical
than him it has to be someone who's
willing to speak on the issues a lot
more aggressively than he is and also
kind of be than him when it comes to
some of the things that also divide his
base you mean Tucker Carls
yes absolutely but talk about we go
right now all right if Ronda santis uh
Michael M tweeted shout out to Michael M
he says he doesn't see how Ronda santis
can continue if he comes in third behind
Nikki Haley there's a little bit more
context there but it's it's an
interesting question about what happens
now in New Hampshire where supposedly
she's pulling at
30% I in the CNN poll yeah I don't know
if I believe that St Anam has her at 22
and Trump up 26 so um and and and in the
CNN the 530 aggregate is 30.3% of
Trump's 43.4 that's shocking are
Democrats a allowed to vot Hampshire I
don't know they are and that may be and
Independence uh but they but they're
expecting I mean they're factoring an
incredibly High turnout I think the
record turnout for Democrats in a
republican priv is like 35% with
Democrats and Independence I do want to
just point out um man free state project
guys what are you doing what's going on
in New Hampshire voting for Nikki Haley
yikes it's a weird State it's a great
state but the way I mean they have
Governor sonunu currently as governor
and he is a rhino's Rhino and so so do
you he ended n too so with that polling
I don't see Nikki Haley dropping out I
don't see Ronda Sanz is pulling in it
and Nikki's got money coming in Ron's
got money running away from him what
person would be dumb enough to invest in
Ronda Sanz after this performance I I
I'm just man Ronda Sanders really just
set himself a blaze and ended his career
I just look for to reading all the
obituaries written about his campaign
tomorrow they're going to like they're
going to he's done yeah now look he's
still within like what 17 votes of Nikki
Haley if he finishes in second he might
be able to limp on but he's going in the
wrong direction well no I mean it was
actually a little bit worse a moment ago
okay so we we'll see but he's down he's
down he's down we will see Trump's
already got 12 delegates they're saying
so we'll see man still it's kind of sad
isn't it the promise of Ronda santis and
his governorship but I do think it's
fair to point out two things the reason
why Florida's doing so well Everyone
likes to Tribute everything to the
executive it's the legislature Florida's
got great representatives and state
senators the ruby red State and then
right when these people pass bills Ronda
sandis gets to sign them here's one to
watch the governor's race the gator oh
Ronda Sanz has taken second place okay
wow yeah there we go look at that now he
now he's actually up by what
17 hey it could turn around for him
maybe he'll be a to but anyway continue
sorry Benny no it's just
so now that Florida is a ruby red state
with a ton of power and then projected
power right so when the census comes the
the state will get four new
congressional seats and so forth and the
government will be insanely powerful Ron
cannot run constitutionally and that
race is already heating up in the State
of Florida as a Florida resident for
who's going to take that role you're
going to see some big names throw their
hatson what does what does Ron do after
this I have no idea I mean everyone
thought well he he started this new
college in Florida called
new College of Florida and he'll it's
like the new Hillsdale College and he is
that for real he will likely appoint
himself to the president of that role
can you explain to me where Rob came
from calling him Rob just to mess with
him okay yeah like and again it's like
that's something that's so stupid but
they got so upset about it yeah the the
trolling from you guys was making them
insane you got to know the Chinese are
very the trolling well that's the thing
it's not just the trolling literally any
even slight constructive criticism of
Ron was met with his campaign people
online diving all over you so this is
what's fascinating you can I know Alx my
executive producer comes on the show
with regularity um great this is
something that we would this is
something that we would track all the
time obviously is when we did it not
just trolling you said slight trolling
not even slight trolling like
constructive feedback so when something
when we didn't say something about like
a big news story
about Ronda santis we'd get trolled so
when Kim Reynolds endorsed Ronda santis
there was a bunch of stuff going on we
didn't mention it in our feed and the
entire uh disantis Team came scorched
Earth for us like tagging us and naming
us because we didn't talk about Rob you
didn't like my post right it's like
crazy it's crazy man like that's insane
yeah so so it's not just trolling him
not even if you just not acknowledging
him that's right wow it's very Mean
Girls energy it was very like um prep
prepubescent like uh High School uh acne
energy I've never seen a campaign like
it in my life I've never seen anything
like it yeah so that's my question I
guess for the table is is have we seen
have we seen anything this bad before
have we ever seen a candidate with such
high hopes fall so spectacularly je Bush
well Jeb well to make to make matters
worse Jeb Bush's senior advisers were
trolling Ronda santis two days ago wow
wow well look look Ron is now up by no
this is more spectacular 65 this is more
spectacular than the Jeb Bush thing Jeb
actually at least was running against
the first time like they're running
against an incumbent so it's kind of
like what's the point this guy has got
it in the bag it's a second term you
know but I I think the thing with Jeb's
campaign is you know the big problem is
it was Jeb and his campaign like who's
gonna you know it's Jeb Bush so many
issues with him but when when Ronda
santz and particularly when he was first
first running uh before everyone had
this uh bad taste in their mouth left by
his his campaign um it was like his to
lose in a sense he was super it was his
campaign came and his people just
totally destroyed any momentum he you
know look look for the longest time I've
I've uh not just I but many of been
talking about where are the young where
where are the Millennials to step up and
enter politics uh or even gen xers
because for the longest time we have
like what do we have like sep and
octogenarians all throughout Congress
and and the issue is is I I've been
saying that it seems like for whatever
reason the millennial generation doesn't
take their role seriously doesn't they
don't view themselves as Leaders as
people should be in charge and when you
look at the Rhonda santis campaign it is
the made for home movie version of Say
Home Alone Like Home Alone one and two
Classics Ronda Sanders campaign Home
Alone 3 have you guys seen Home Alone
three no what is it it's kind of a joke
horrible film it's kind of a joke but I
mean it as an actual analogy thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net